okay spoiler warning if you haven't seen
season 2 episode 4 of and just like that
you might want to turn your Manolo
blonics around and come back a little
later on yes the latest installment of
the Sex and the City reboot series
featured some impressive cameos as well
as an unexpected threesome courtesy of
Miss Miranda Hobbs it all started after
Chase ex-husband Lyle came into town and
the pair reminisce on their polyamorous
passed over drinks who's Jenny Jenny was
kind of our girlfriend for a few months
yeah we were probably Pioneers meanwhile
I was cutting up carrot sticks for
Brady's lunchbox later that night Shea
and Miranda began making love but things
took a turn when Lyle woke up and the
twosome became a threesome Miranda
agreed she was game for the new until a
leg cramp quickly changed her mood so
Miranda oh is that a yes
yes
just isn't me so just just you should
you should carry on seriously I'm I'm
I'm I'm good with it
oh
hey
you really didn't have to stop I meant
that
I know
I missed you and over on Park Avenue
Charlotte realized Harry's orgasm was
missing the usual sticky finale which
led to an interesting lunch conversation
well I've always been a fan of mail it's
like the confetti at a parade it's like
it's like finale of fireworks on the 4th
of July I love you so much right now
meanwhile Carrie is left horrified after
being asked to join an online magazine
called Vivant which caters to an older
demographic and is run by her former
Vogue editor Enid Frick played by
Candice Bergen women our age are grossly
underrepresented in the media so I I'd
love it if you could get involved you're
perfect for it oh my gosh
thank you thank you later in the episode
Carrie is invited to an elite Gathering
of women including Gloria Steinem who
brings out her inner fangirl forgive me
for asking would you mind terribly being
in a photo with Ina did me I would love
that oh wow okay would you take it oh
absolutely thank you